folks Joe and Sal here from the taste
buds podcast we are doing our very first
live live stream episode live stream
episode when May 10th May 10th mark your
calendars tickets are going to be
available soon for pre-sale there's
going to be a ton of surprises there's
gonna be guests there's gonna be a
Premiere that night of should we tease
it not yet okay not yet but it's a big
one it's a big something yeah something
very big we've been teasing it for a
while it's coming finally the live
stream May 10th also merch is still
available for the taste buds podcast go
and get you some uh it's available at my
website jodarosainfo.com or
salvocanocomedy.com and also we are both
on the road doing live dates we've got
tons we've only got time to name a few I
next coming up will be in Michigan in
several cities uh and then also in
Illinois for several cities and in New
York at the crane theater anyway just
check out my website jodyroseinfo.com
for all the info on that plus Joey roses
Remington Street Manhattan Joey get a
sandwich affordable guy sandwiches and
drinks I'm on the road with the guys uh
this is our first tour since before the
pandemic our fifth International tour
tickets are on sale right now and
impracticaljokerslive.com there's tons
of cities and tons more will be added
next up March 24th in Green Bay the 25th
of Milwaukee the 26th in Rosemont then
we're going to Seattle and Portland in
April as well as Bangor Maine and Boston
again and then later on so forth it's a
lot of Ohio a lot of Texas uh two in St
Louis and practicaljokerslive.com brand
new episodes of Impractical Jokers every
Thursday night at 10 o'clock on TBS and
True TV season 10 out right now taste
buds they coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic I'm talking folks welcome to
t-a-s I said b-a-t-t-l-e oh wow all
right dude no roll with it do it again
okay
b-a-t-t-t-h-e boots
by taste buds yeah very good today it's
good to see you buddy as well I feel
like we didn't I'm sorry I didn't mean I
like your Aztec uh forward uh cardigan
rich I see this more snow flaky
Christmasy maybe a hybrid yeah yeah I
kind of wore today because I was like
this is kind of it I leave tomorrow to
do some shows in Louisiana and and then
Austin so it's all Southern and I was
like when I get back from that we're
going to be pretty well into March and
it'll still be chilly but I think this
is kind of The Last Licks window for a
sweater that feels this seasonally
seasonal I like how you um
dress up casual you dress up a casual
outfit I like that I like to you're in
between and I like that it's the
versatility of it is I I exclusively
work cardigans for a long long time yeah
I got I got actually got labeled as a
guy who only wears Cardigans I like to
look like a man who knows what he wants
and knows who he is hmm and I believe
how does this look make you feel like
you know what you want I was just being
fun okay yeah I I uh I also believe that
the listener can hear what you're
wearing
they can really they can hear it
I learned that from the Walter Winchell
movie did you see that movie starring
Stanley Tucci what's it about it's about
Walter Winchell no but what's the name
of the movie windshield
no I didn't see it about the great
uh news reporter Walter Winchell The
Godfather of Gossip the first ever uh oh
he spawned that whole thing like the
page is like the original yeah he was
like Howard Stern in the 40s or whatever
really yeah but uh he uh
but he when he gets his big radio gig
the company CBS whatever it is they buy
them all this like they fit him for this
new wardrobe
and he goes who cares like nobody can
see what I'm wearing and they go but
they can hear it Walter
that stuck with you yeah and I'm like
I mean look I'm not like all decked out
today but I just mean like I do believe
that you should put yourself together a
little bit
you know maybe not sure because when I'm
home I'll do stuff in pajama pants if
I'm home three days in a row I'm in
pajamas for three days straight nah I
might I might throw on sweats after a
shot but I'm not in I'm in nothing but
pajamas or sweats I came to your house
the other day my pajamas you and full
bed head yeah you didn't even bother to
be like you I don't give a [__] I when
anybody's coming over I check my hair I
do you know to an extent but honestly I
was against the clock and then I was
just like it doesn't matter to me
good for you I walk around with Bed Head
I'm home I mean what are you gonna do
good for you in your life yeah I'm uh we
all we all wake up I feel as if I'm
being judged at all times at home
oh yeah even when you're alone oh yeah I
think that who's judging you then people
like you that they're somewhere else
talking about me
you know that's tough
I have a question when you're depressed
you ever just dress up in your house
like like you're going out but stay home
no oh my God no wow I don't know I tried
it a few weeks ago it doesn't work oh
okay because that was interesting I was
gonna say I could I never thought of
that as you said it I was like wow that
might help also corduroy in a sweater I
was gonna say pimp what is dressing up
for you I'd love to see your pajamas
because you you
you talk about versatility your outfit
is
today
I go to the gym in corduroys it's funny
yeah what is your pajamas
uh I think V bought them they're like
weird colorful fleece pajamas okay yeah
that's how I see it
um I my mom told me a story about when
they were when she was young and her
brother my uncle who's rest in peace
he's gone but
it this it it broke my heart to this day
it breaks my heart she said he would get
he would save up his money that he made
working his after-school job whatever
and he would buy suits Saturday night
suits to like you know get dressed up
again she goes then you get all dressed
up in a suit but then he would have
nowhere to go and he would just sit on
the couch and watch TV in his suit and
it would now he eventually got married
and had a family I mean so it worked out
it worked out but like it really it was
it it gives a peek into your lineage
though
I'm not going to say something that DNA
didn't make its way to you well I'm
adopted
okay behaviorals but yeah it it it and I
swear to God to this day if I because I
have like gotten showered and gotten
dressed and then decided like yeah I
don't think I feel like going anywhere
sometimes when I do that I'll shout out
for the motivation yeah but I'll force
myself to go out
when I do that because that story of my
uncle makes me so sad that I'm like I
can't sit here negative into a positive
yeah and you know who are we kidding I'm
a man about town you know I always got a
place yeah yeah they know my name
everybody knows my neighbor somewhere
yeah
I need a pop I go into Joey roses they
shake hands with a few fans
I get a free sandwich sometimes we go
bar hopping off Ben we'll go bar hopping
it'll take me like four five six bars
everybody knows your name
that's all I ever wanted
you got it you got it uh the uh what'd
you do in L.A La is not that type of
place if you believe it or not
complained a lot
uh but you couldn't be you over there
not this version I swear to God
uh my crew of people that I hung out
with friends in no way
uh some of them you know uh but
they would say they would say when you
leave town we don't all hang out like
you're like the you get it going and
they would also say if I went on the
road for a little while I would I'd come
back they would go I haven't been this
hung over
I wasn't hungover the whole time you
weren't you were gone
uh but but I was very proud of that I
was very always very touched that they
were like no you like you like get the
thing going yeah because I was always
because it was a lot of I hung I try to
be that as well you do yeah I hang with
a lot of couples out there because
couples that's kind of a big thing out
there and uh like more
I realize it's a weird sense
in New York go out with
boys
and Sirens go by the uh you could in New
York you can go out almost anywhere and
see a good amount of single people
of all ages La it is not like that it is
it is a lot of couples like it just is
like it's it's just it's just different
it's a very Suburban type City so most
of my friends were in relationships so I
was always like come on we all got to go
to here and we got to do that because I
was like I'm still trying to have sex
everybody like let's go like let's get a
party going you know so uh
um but you know it was it was I spent a
lot
I don't think I ever told you this story
I remember I moved from Echo Park to
Atwater Village and at Water Village was
my favorite place that I ever lived when
I was in L.A where's that geographically
it's next to Glendale uh
uh and
it was the most like New York you could
get because it was like you could there
were like coffee shops around you could
walk to stuff and
and there were some cool dive bars and
stuff like that so
um I like that water a lot but I go I I
had gotten into this Habit in L.A
because I was so depressed I would just
buy things all the time I would just
constantly be buying retail therapy babe
yeah like collecting things that I
didn't
I remember I said to Kurt bronholler
when I moved to Atwater Village I go
uh I just realized how depressed I am or
I've been and he's like how and I go I
have a trash bag full of He-Man figures
doing because I would like literally
like I would walk in Echo Park when I
lived there
and I would just like my goal for like
to get out of for the day would be to
walk to the comic book store
and I would like buy an action figure
because I was just like there so it made
me feel like I was doing something you
know what I mean like yeah it was like
just stand up was so much lesser there
you know you can you write but you only
write for so long like you know it was
just like there was so I feel like L.A
was so much downtime man if you weren't
like on a show or something like that
how long were you there
like five years
and then I would come back here
and go to like big Jay's Fourth of July
rooftop party right and everybody would
be there yeah
that's where I would start seeing you
yeah but we started becoming like more
like friends or whatever and it was like
oh
people do this like there's like like
comedians where you came from here I
know but you you would forget because
you go there like there's no the store
the store has Club hangs there there's
no camrad
except for the comedy story you can get
a club hand going a little bit but even
that it would break apart quickly and
early there wasn't the thing there with
comedians where they all hung out and
it's kind of going away here yeah what's
going away here what year did you know
you wanted to move but you stayed like
you hate did you hate it every single
year
I didn't the first year I was unhappy we
were like I'm an L.A guy now yes
for the first year I was unhappy and
then Joey all these things started
happening I started booking all the
stuff I started getting all this stuff
and I was like oh my God that's why you
move here and I was like oh I'm on my
way like
La is great and three years of that to
the day it just stopped which is what
happens out there it'll just stop and
then you have to coast and you have to
keep your sanity and when it stopped I
started to be like I don't think I like
this place because I had time to like
sit and live in that place yeah and
everybody would say you know bird always
go compared to where DeRosa compared to
where it sucks ever you know what I mean
like that was kind of everybody's
attitude like this is as good as
anywhere else
and I was like yeah I guess but like
eventually I was like no I I disagree I
don't like this as much as anywhere else
I don't nothing against people that like
it I just I was like I just didn't like
the day-to-day yeah
I know a lot of people that moved out
there and moved back
Mark Maron put it best
when I was moving back he goes I hear
you're pussing out man and I was like
yeah I'm just kind of done I think and I
was like I just missed New York you know
I miss walking outside and seeing people
and he goes yeah man you can't walk
outside here and get that charge and I
was like that's exactly what I've been
trying to that's the sentence I've been
trying to formulate for six years out
here I I don't yeah I'm like it's just
something's just different and it and
that thing missing doesn't work for me
not all the time there are times I feel
like I could live in LA to play back
with a vengeance you came down to the
Lower East Side and planted a flag down
there yeah now I'm stuck here I can't
leave now you're a neighborhood face
I saw a cartoon the other day there was
a complete ripoff of Mr Rogers
like like so much so that it had to be
they had to have sanctioned it I was
like sitting there and I'm like look at
me there's a ripple it was like
a fox or something and he was like it's
a beautiful day and then he put on his
shoes and he the trolley and all that
stuff and I was like everything's being
remade they rebranded Barney all that
stuff's gonna how do you Rebrand Barney
they made it like a cartoon but it's
still a purple dinosaur yeah but it's
like you know polished still the same
theme song I think so no joke so there's
this thing called Autos psychosis psycho
auto correction something that the
government used to use as a torture
technique when they would play the same
music over and over and over to drive
someone insane and there's documented
cases of it and they did it to get the
cult out of there and Waco and a few
other places and I forget which one but
they use the Barney theme song uh as a
torture technique that they played over
and over and over and blasted it in some
scenario
see look at this the top 20 songs
oh God wait which Britney song
oh that's not so bad I love bodies I I
wouldn't be upset about that not hearing
that dude over and over and over and
over I feel like any song over and over
and over would be a torture song
wouldn't it I guess I understand man
Raspberry Beret I don't know why
there it is like like the Barney one is
very obvious like you know
really
beautiful people's the best Marilyn
Manson song yeah but oh
you know I mean I can see it
what scars of the crucifix is that
Marilyn Manson
decide a song called [__] Your Gods
decide how'd they make that list
I can see that man
that's right off the bat like David Gray
Babylon I once wrote like 20 pages of a
script listening to nothing but that
song on Loop
what yeah I don't know why what song is
that David Gray Babylon but what is it
it's like a acoustic guitar song I'm
blanking though sing it uh
I think it's like going away going away
I hate songs like this you know it
though right what was the script about
it had nothing to do with the song it's
just that the song was like easy enough
easy listening enough like it came on
one time and I was like writing and I
was like writing a lot and then the next
song came on and it was jarring and so I
just hit back and I kept writing and I
was like oh this song's not bothering me
so then I put it on Loop and then I
would every night when I used to come to
to my desk to write again I just would
put that on I don't know I was in this I
don't love the song I don't know the guy
nothing it just completely Ran So that
song was so Paul simony yeah oh God I
hate that stuff yeah you're the one to
run this video by you guys just to see
see what you think
all right
I mean is this food she's gonna make now
no stepping on the ground
picking up ramen in the back come on
this is just reviews
I mean who's
even mean
we'll see
somebody she's doing like a tailgate
how'd she
so it's cooked and then dumped hey man
this is a joke
you hungry did you need any food we have
we just made to just go no way no
[__] do you need any food or anything
man they stopped on the side of the road
and they're feeding a homeless man 20
bucks I mean we don't have
we only have 20 bucks but we have we
have some ramen noodles we can give you
man
hey
actually back in the truck bed you want
to say they're fresh they're hot we just
made a ton of ramen noodles and we're
just driving around giving it to people
it's it's people that just so just use
honestly just go back and just I don't
understand
there's gonna be nothing it's literally
people that just want to give it a try
go back there and grab it just go back
oh my God thank you yeah
and they want us to believe this is real
what the [__] that sucks I mean maybe it
is real 10.8 million views
look at this kind-hearted woman feeds
hundreds out of her truck they show one
it's such a lie that is such a lie and
the guy sitting there with a perfectly
made cardboard sign in the Park yeah I
know yeah there's a props Department
sticker on the back of it
like why not literally give like
self-served cup of nude like why make a
a
pickup truck cab full of and where'd she
make it
in a truck it's insulting that she's
trying to tell us that how did she make
it in the truck you need hot water
she well maybe she heated the water and
filled it
well I don't know I mean it it got made
it's almost like disrespectful because
that's going to waste the water must
have been hot it's completely going away
so you're wasting food come on and and
the irony is is if it if it is just a
joke too then you're really you're
really [__] like you know it's really
[__] uh uh uh uh hypocritical and it
gets more views than like a sitcom yeah
it's already begun and it's not going to
end and we can't stop it no it's bad
it's bad but yeah there's no you don't
need there's no such thing anymore as
cream rising to the top there's no
quality control and then this is we're
so saturated with this that the that
younger people think that this is what
entertainment is and we're just dumbing
ourselves down this is I don't want to
get into this I want to complain again
but I it's bleak
[Laughter]
it's horrible
no matter what happens I love you tattoo
look at that that's shout out oh wait
this is they came to my show
no wait
well no because your brother and sister
came to my show and asked me to sign
uh something because they were gonna get
it tattooed on them always a mistake uh
but I don't think this was it because I
think I wrote my name uh now to any of
you that have any type of no pressure
tattoos taste buds or anything else
thank you it's a commitment yeah uh it
shows your love for the show we
appreciate you I don't always think it's
the right move because for obvious
reasons but it's very flattering and
humbling and we do appreciate you guys
send us pictures I think it's a great
move I'm you're not going to get any
judgment for me yeah
well I have Jaden Smith on my thighs so
yeah live your life nothing here live
your life you know German ice cream
parlor introduces Cricket flavored
scoops
nah I'm not gonna do it
it's just dead crickets and ice cream
yeah I mean I wouldn't eat it have you
ate insects at all well you know what I
would eat it I would try it
I would try it I saw the high-end
restaurants now are using ants a lot
yeah yeah I would I would
it wouldn't like I wouldn't be excited
to do it but I wouldn't like barf from
it
hard pass you know what I mean I don't
think I'd like it but I don't I don't
think I would like to get would you guys
try some on air if I bought some I would
eat like a candied Cricket or something
but like not like cockroach like there's
certain bugs like where no worms
probably not never seen on people eat
those Madagascar cockroaches and like
crunchy and then all the gooeyness in
them say what happens in Temple of Doom
remember they eat the coffee like a Fear
Factor or something yeah yeah remember
they eat the cockroaches in Temple of
Doom yeah
but aren't they like related to lobsters
or something they feel the same to me
the same oh
wait what's inside this is why it's
crazy that we eat lobsters too look what
they look like just that it's been
normalized what said that you know
Lobster started out as a very very poor
food
it was like it was it was for it was for
low-income people it was not a delicacy
in any way shape or form
which I kind of don't understand how it
is now because they're still they're
still in abundance it's not a hard you
know what I mean yeah why is it so
expensive yeah
lobsters why is that that price point
then the hell was that
was a weird Buzz
sorry let me
oh you know
we're not in the middle of anything I'll
tell you what's going on right now later
is it like personal
no but you'll understand okay
um
the uh we'll be going here that was good
I was gonna make a joke and then I lost
it like I don't know we got to get our
energy up yeah our energy sucks right
now I know I'm like very comfortable I
know I'm too comfortable we got to
replace this couch
why it's not comfortable
but you just said you're too comfortable
it like you sink into it in the wrong
way
like it's not comfortable I gotta be
honest I can't see us replacing the
couch
real picture
throwing this perfectly good catch out
and spending money on another why would
we have to throw it out no we just we
just replace it
put this somewhere else
and where do we get the other couch I'll
take this couch
is this just your way of getting a free
[__] couch no wait wait wait wait
wait wait
this is what I don't like this couch
you'll take the couch no no I don't want
the couch I don't like this couch but
we're gonna get another couch
you know that there are stores that sell
you want to throw out this couch we
don't just throw it in the couch you got
a whole
expansion of rooms here we can put it
somewhere what what is wrong with the
couch it's not a great couch look at the
way the pillows collapse when you're
sitting on it like pimp has said
repeatedly when we say we the we don't
like the way we look in the video so go
I think it's the couch I think I look
pale
I look
I don't even maybe we get you a pillow
for behind your back
hey back against this thing nobody get
you pillows and create a nice hey look
at this this thing is just like it's
just oh you're leaning on the pillow you
know
sat back it's gonna play like a couch
does we're all you know we're all
getting all comfy on it
what's your dream couch
you sent us a picture of a couch we all
said oh that's great oh that was a cover
for this coach yeah oh well let's do
that anyway
okay yeah
that's loud and it's not gonna fit nice
oh then mix it yeah well we could do it
but if it fits exact though how's it
going to fit exactly we don't know sorry
DeRosa that's that's annoying you can
try it I'd almost rather have two of
these chairs
do you want to hop to the chair now you
can go to the chair now if you want I
might want to go to the chair
but almost that would look cooler that
would look cooler in front of the sign
this couch doesn't look great all right
hold on let me move
[Laughter]
it is better it's already propping up
yeah yeah it's better there's something
about that thing man it's because you
are comfortable I think
comfortable but not I mean for me it's
only because this is my fourth this is
my fourth one today I think I'm running
a little bit of steam but normally I
don't I mean normally I'm pretty good
with the four right but I think I'm I
think I'm feeding I I will feed over
energy if you were higher energy and
vice versa we're probably we're probably
putting ourselves into a cycle there's
you sink into that couch in not a good
way like it's like it's it's I wouldn't
use the word comfortable I would you say
it's a it's a tiring couch I'm tired
like you sit in it and it starts to pull
I feel like it extracts energy from you
like a like a energy vampire like Colin
Robinson uh yes yes yes that sort of
thing so anyway
here's why
I like Capri Sun wait we didn't
b-a-t-t-l-e come on babe come on get
yourself together here I think it's
saying that would would just make us
know that we got to say it right now
okay we need salty though we gotta get
we
this is stupid all right
you with me yeah
all right we're gonna do it it's time to
get salty oh they're gonna be attle buds
oh boy
Sal what's going on with you dude are
you having some kind of you having some
kind of sugar drop or something oh wow I
don't know what's going on I said we
need to do a salt you just moved to a
different chair because you were dying
yeah it's a bad couch
we need to do a salty okay we gotta get
our I get it you want to insult me I get
it no we got to get our energy up How's
that gonna get our energy out why why
wouldn't I love you get RNG up because
it's too nice
you're already being coddled by that
couch okay you need to you need a little
kick in your ass right now
I want you in fact I want you to insult
me first
you ready yeah you sure yeah all right
yeah I can't tell if you're doing a bit
or something right now
I don't know I'm not doing anything
it's weird right am I wrong he's being
weird what do you think the bit is
though I don't understand we're all
confused by you right now I'm literally
just responding to you I'm just what am
I what explain to me what you think I'm
doing we don't know but then I don't you
can't even identify what you think is
making sure you're kind of you're you're
sort of just almost acting as if the
cameras aren't rolling
why this is five characters you're going
yeah yeah oh I'm not expounding yes okay
I'm saying meet me here are we doing the
[__] we're doing this right okay yeah
yeah yeah all right yeah all right well
maybe he just feels alone on the big
couch baby you abandoned me all right
listen that couch is no good
honestly I think you get up off of it
I'm tempted to see if you get off you
come sit over here for a minute I want
to see if your energy change
come sit over here
I'm telling you you're gonna feel it
immediately
it's time to beat
don't you feel a spike I certainly feel
propped up more firm higher forward see
it's more of a position to have a
conversation in all right yeah you sink
into that I get what you're saying
totally all right do you see the shift
in energy you just had I see that I
don't know if my energy is gonna raise
but I do feel the difference in the
couch and its application you're
speaking in full sentences now that's a
step in the right direction a minute ago
you were not you were almost just making
noises
um
[Music]
all right ready we'll switch back and
forth through the episode
okay all right yeah all right let's do a
salty all right it's starting to get
salty
the more I know you you think that you
would become easier to deal with
it's just the ninth wonder of the world
that is the exact opposite the more I
get to know you the more difficult it is
to navigate your Waters okay very all
right fine fair enough ready
that was that was by the way that was
that was pretty mild that was a great
one okay I thought it was great okay
ready yes
enough with you being late enough enough
you were late today again you're 48
years old together not 48. get a watch I
don't understand what the issue is yeah
well I'm coming from another Borough
okay well today I had uh
something
and I was probably 20 15 20 minutes
later okay but you know it's you know
get a day plan well one one of the
things not the primary thing that made
me late but one of the things was my my
Uber dropped after waiting for like
seven minutes for it so that was a that
was a chunk and then there was a little
something else okay but but but sure
point taken I I I've run late my whole
life yeah oh yeah I know it's it's
actually a function of like my ADHD and
stuff like that so oh part of it is I've
been working on it with a therapist okay
work harder we'll leave it at that
it's my insult
he's salty to me right he says enough
with it you're 48 I'm not he's 48
uh stop being on time and I literally
say you know what I identified the
reasons and I actually have therapy I'm
working on what you just said I tell him
that it's harder and harder to deal with
them the more I know him no resolution
whatsoever not working on it fair enough
but you're not working on it you are
like I'm going with her before I'm not
working on it I'm in therapy buddy I
thought that that was evident
I didn't think I had to say trust me I'm
working on it
I got to go home at six o'clock today so
I can deal with the anxiety of leaving
my apartment for three days tomorrow
yeah I'm working on it trust me I'm
going through it folks Joe DeRosa here
to talk to you about
gametime.co Gametime dot Co
what is gametime.co well I'm gonna tell
you uh you ever try to buy tickets to uh
maybe your favorite sporting event and
it's stressful and it's a headache and
it sucks uh yeah well it shouldn't be
game time is a fast and easy way to buy
tickets to all sporting events and not
just sporting events music events comedy
events Theater events things that are
happening near you that you want to go
see they've got killer deals on last
minute tickets with the best price
guarantee so you can stop stressing over
getting the tickets and and just focused
on what you should be which is getting
ready to have a great time at the thing
you want to go see uh I I like the game
time dot Co I keep stressing that
because it's not it's co all right get
that get that correct but I like the
game time experience uh because I like
that they're offering flash uh Flash
Deals on last minute tickets I like that
it's easy to find and buy the tickets to
every kind of event and you're I find
that just locating tickets is hard
sometimes it's really hard sometimes
like you got you you start googling the
person's name in the city or the event
name and the city and then and then you
find links to things that aren't correct
and I don't know I like that they're
kind of putting it all Under One Roof
for you making it real easy to locate
what's going on and I also like a low
price or low lowest price rather
guarantee uh it's just it's a good
service so forget planning months in
advance game time has deals on tickets
right up to the day of the event that's
also awesome do you ever buy a ticket
way in advance because you're worried
and then you get closer and you're like
uh what did I do
game time folks game time
you can also get images of your seat
before you buy that's pretty helpful
helpful uh so you know what to expect
when you arrive I've bought bad seats
before uh anyway and buy a ticket in a
matter of seconds two Taps you're set
that's it this is easy it's convenient
it's there to service you it's there to
help you get out to have the fun you
want to have so download the game time
app create an account and use code taste
buds you're gonna get twenty dollars off
your first purchase terms apply okay but
again create an account and redeem the
code taste buds for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price
guaranteed folks Joe DeRosa here coming
to you from a very different angle in a
very different room without wearing my
glasses why because I want to talk to
you about one of our favorite sponsors
here at the taste buds podcast factor
factor is America's number one ready to
eat meal kit get nutritious Chef
prepared meals delivered straight to
your door leaving you the time and
energy to tackle everything you need to
do on that lengthy to-do list I've got a
long one myself
talking about the list people don't go
there anyway I like Factor quite a bit
these are smart meals with about 550
calories or less a lot of the times I'm
too busy to cook I know you can relate
to that we all are uh and you can get
these great amazing delicious never
frozen meals that are ready in just two
minutes my favorite part is the never
Frozen part sometimes you'll buy a
frozen meal because you're in a rush or
something and then cooking the frozen
meal number one is frozen which is not
great but also then cooking the frozen
meal is a pain you're like you got to
cook it for six minutes and then you
gotta take off the plastic from this
part and then stir this then put it in
another seven minutes you're like I
should just cook something from at that
point anyway
Factor never Frozen two minutes ready to
go flavor packed meal meals delicious
and things that can fit whatever your
dietary needs are keto options vegan and
veggie options a calorie smart Protein
Plus options this is these are this is
what you're gonna get to choose from
every week 34 Chef prepared dietitian
approved weekly options it's great I
like Factor it allow it allows you to
cut back on the takeout it allows you to
eat something that is decent for you to
eat when you don't have the time to make
it and I also like that it's always the
perfectly prepared portion uh you eat it
you feel full and you're ready to go and
by full I mean satisfied I don't mean
like uh flow you don't want to feel like
that and you also don't want to feel
like you needed to eat more factors hit
it right on the nose so here's what I
want you to do head to factormeals.com
tastebuds50 use promo code taste buds
five zero to get 50 off your first box
that's code taste buds five zero at
factorial
wheels.com slash tastebuds50 to get 50
off your first box all right time two
b-a-t-t-l-e Buzz okay folks today we're
doing high C versus Capri Sun These Are
the Champions
of the children's Juice drink market now
I would throw in Hawaiian Punch remember
a little bit I don't think Hawaiian
Punch no pun packs a punch today that I
did when we were kids I agree as you
said on the very first episode of taste
buds Hawaiian Punch went from how many
ounces to how many ounces right under
our noses you point that out yeah it
dropped in quality but Hawaiian Punch is
is in the fruit drink realm obviously
but it stands alongside more of like the
sunny days and that sort of thing when I
say the kids Juice drink
world right the reason I am saying it's
these two high C and uh uh Capri Sun
Capri Sun does the pouch Hi-C does the
Box this is it dude you're taking it too
big these are two giants now I will tell
you this I see when I was little I I
always remember it as it as a can a big
can that you had to plug that you had to
open a can open on both sides and pour
out you know that you know what's funny
I don't don't remember it ever being in
the I I'm sure I saw this Supermarket
that's how they sold it there was no
plastic bottle it was always a metal can
and you had to take the the can opener
that you opened like not like yeah the
one that you like punch a triangle into
it and you have to do it on both sides
so the air could Escape so it could pour
out and that's yeah and then when we
when we didn't finish it we just put
like aluminum foil over and put it in
the yeah you always have to put that
Cellophane in with the rubber band or
whatever the hell yeah
um but yeah but juice box I think I see
uh and then juice pouch you know there
is no other juice pouch though you're
imitated often I see is imitated often I
don't know another I guarantee you Capri
Sun probably has a patent
well I am high C okay uh so I was Capri
Sun as he just alluded to uh I'm gonna
come right out of the gate and say uh we
got you beat because that's so cooler I
saw Ecto Cooler just now as pip was
Googling and I mean for a major
franchise brand to cling on to your to
your drink I mean that your your drink's
doing pretty well at that point there
had to be some major collabs with Capri
Sun uh and I gotta tell you the Ecto
Cooler next to high sea Orange
to me was life I mean High Ecto Cooler
was so good I agree it was so good I
agree uh but I love both of these but I
think if you're going to talk about the
Titan King the queen Bish of all high
sea orange and high sea fruit punch I
mean I don't think anybody is even
flexing with them the thing about it is
is that when I think of high C sure I'm
like that's a big one but when I think
of high scene using of juice boxes one
million companies from the organic
companies to everywhere in between have
juice boxes so when you say a kid is a
juice box it's no longer synonymous to
me with high C the juice box could be
any single company any single flavor any
single not even geared toward kids
necessarily when I say the pouch there's
only one one thing I think of that's
Capri Sun nobody is it's it's you're
duplicated and imitated Capri Sun is not
oh look at this
uh Capri Sun has a with your precious
pouch long history of mold look at that
that's mold in the bottom of the pouch
dude that's disgusting but that is
disgusting I've never encountered that
and like I'm sure you could put in mold
in a juice box and find that as well uh
now viral like they're yeah they got
caught with a lot of mold it did yeah
yeah
my first one amongst us who is without
sin cast the first stone a mom's a mom
told a story of her 10 year old boy
drinking from his Capri Sun he started
choking and said oh mommy this is nasty
which is also something I said to my
date last week Lily folks listen anyway
uh
she couldn't you said to your date oh
mommy this is nasty yeah
Dirty Talk joke oh like you're having
sex oh mommy this is oh that's good okay
okay thank you
welcome back to the show
[Laughter]
Caprice son I'm glad hey babe got the
energy today I look forward to seeing
that
I did book first we both are on low
energy you moved here because of your
low energy you're the first one to point
it out by the way you skipped this part
where he pulled a worm out of his mouth
drinking Capri's son
that was a genuine gag that's disgusting
uh oh my God that's so gross this is not
tarnishing Caprice son's image on the
hole in this argument I mean I can say
it's tarnishing talk I mean you could
Google any single food and be like you
know rat in it a worm in it mold in it
and it's gonna pull up this is not I'm
not gonna
I'm not gonna associate Capri Sun with a
moldy bag and and that's it it's out the
window well hold on a second these
occurrences are not very rare given that
they've kept happening over the years
most recent response to the company is a
bit of a head scratcher on September
2018 and irate dad posted on Facebook so
tonight after dinner our oldest asked
for some juice Capri Sun I grabbed one
for the refrigerator and know something
odd about it it seemed low in content I
take a closer look at the packaging and
don't notice a hole or anything I shake
it up some only to find an unknown
substance floating in the package
uh what is Capri Sun's response though
uh what's the substance it's mold mold
uh the company told mold and heist in
Juice Box the company told today in a
statement that this was an isolated case
the uh the author then writes in
parentheses ah sure and they doubled
down saying we understand it's
unpleasant but the mold is naturally
occurring just like if you left an apple
on your counter for too long that's the
come on what's the degrees unexpired
I don't need this person I don't need
the editorializing of this person it was
so bad that they changed the bottom of
the pouch to be see-through
they did yeah permanently oh I didn't
know that yeah
wait they changed it
yeah they made it transparent the bottom
of the Capri Sun and then you and then
they had mold in the see-through ones
which we saw earlier oh yeah so you can
spot it but by the way is it expired
probably not what is this guy buying
Capri Suns a year in advance you never
know Costco BJ's big markets like that
Sam's Club listen fair enough listen
juice boxes are fun right I don't know
when they came out but I know that when
they came into my life a juice boxes fun
there's something about the little Bendy
straw with the sharp edge that you poke
through and they're fun and they were
the most fun thing until
Capri Sun dropped and the pouch is more
fun than the box it just is I love
putting the straw through more I love
that you can squeeze the pouch in
addition to sucking for the juice and I
love love love
I've never not finishing that pouch
sucking until it's completely flat and
then blowing it back up to look full
size and setting it back down again
there's something there's something in
in that process that just I think that's
what everyone latches on to I'm not
going to sit here and tell you you can't
have fun with a bladder you can okay uh
you can but I will say this you got a
gimmick and that's all you got I will
say you could also use Capri Sun as a
weapon if you need it
how the edges are very sharp oh I say
the edges of a juice box first of all I
also crunch my juice box and I do get it
I do get a feeling of satisfaction from
that because it's more like a beer can
crunch it's more of a man's crunch I've
also re-blown up a juice box uh after
I've done that and it and it gives a
very satisfying almost Crackle Pop when
you do so now here's what I will say and
this is the the sucking it out and
blowing back up is Capri Sun all the way
sorry don't try to don't try to give the
attribute but I'll tell you this I'll
tell you this with Capri Sun
uh and this is why the box is better
and by the way we should we should focus
on less waste for me we should focus on
not just a box because it's high c not
drink boxes but I will say this is why
the box is better
I'm putting the straw in the Box
10 out of 10. it happens Capri Sun
I'm looking at a 60 65 success ratio
we're getting that that straw is a pain
you gotta know what you're doing and
when you get it in the satisfaction is
better it's satisfying to get it and you
got to know what you're doing and when
you know what you're doing it goes into
the first trial you actually feel
accomplished and at the end of it the
little treat of blowing it back up it's
a whole experience a Capri Sun well wait
what's what's but what's the strategy to
get this destroyed
well I like to hold firm on the bottom
of the bag so that the top is a little
bit taut and then you have to hit it
with laser Precision accuracy okay and
you can't do it soft you have to follow
through okay another thing I like about
that is is is
what you said before when you Crusher
you remind me of garbage I'm I'm
conscious this is recyclable and it's
much more of a less of a carbon
footprint
what
a Capri Sun flattened out is like a
sheet of small piece sheet of loose leaf
by the way are you a big bulky carton is
is pretty Sun are really bad for the
environment yep chill
so I'm sure cartons are too
why because they're straws because no
because of the plastic pouch buddy
you're talking about plastic mine is
cardboard mine is juice boxes made of
the environment you're gonna find the
same article no you're not cardboard
they started putting water in cardboard
cartons instead of bottles because of
this cardboard is the best thing you
could the best type of portable
container you could drink something out
of you you've got a you've got a thing
I'm not sure if it's aluminum I'm not
sure if it's if it's plastic I don't
know what the hell that pouch is made
out of do you I don't I think it's
aluminum no
have if there's wax on it five years if
there's wax on the coating of the
cardboard
and it and there is my friend five years
to decompose all right what's the
decomposers to decompose yeah yeah
what's the decompose of a Capri Sun
insta baby you're recycling that [__]
you're
you're recycling that [__] yeah yeah I'm
sure every every six-year-old is very
eco-conscious making sure these go into
the recycling bin Capri Sun
look at that in wait pimp you wait wait
in 300 years you will be gone and
forgotten but the Capri Sun but the
Caprice on You Dragon third grade will
still be in a landfill
why what does it comprise though ah
something terrible
it's plastic that's what it said yeah on
my worst day five years on your best day
20. so let's start there let's start
with can I say something else orange or
white and neck to cool you're right
right but I mean you could say I guess
fruit punch babe come on but but
after that I mean I really think Capri
Sun is more uh creative with their
flavors I dare you to name me three
Capri sunflips all right here's the the
real also the original Capri Sun I put
up against those well hold on made of
layers of plastic and aluminum the drink
pouch is difficult or impossible to
recycle according to a coalition of
environmental groups and as of 2015 a
jaw-dropping 1.4 billion pouches ended
up in U.S landfills
they only know that number because
that's what was manufactured and they're
saying it's not getting broken down
is
big news big news show fake news
dude it is it's awesome it's the truth
who makes Capri Sun let's go up to
relater on these I'll tell you this too
you leave a you leave a high seed juice
box in the Sun
for an hour two hours three hours fire
hours I would still drink it and not
where it'd be gross could it be hot if
you left the Capri Sun in the sun same
thing Joe no dude five hours
sick dudes five hours I'm just chilling
son it's not like it's not nothing
happens that didn't happen to the high
sea and I have a question as far as that
goes how does every when it's in
shipment isn't it red hot in the back of
a truck anyway
oh probably yeah but I would but but
what you just said is false and here's
why it's false vinyl records
that you listen to they will warp within
at times in in direct sunlight not even
extreme heat just directionally they can
warp within a few hours literally within
a few hours if that can happen
that Capri Sun sitting in hot sunlight
for a long time yeah I'm not drinking
coffee out of Styrofoam
huh I mean I I can't give you that
comparison that an LP like a vinyl
record warps in a few hours all right
then I'll give you something better we
can get off the environment I'll give
you this now these two drinks these two
drinks have worked their way into this
is it they're in right you got Capri
Suns and Lunchables period boom right
nice collab and then every every
Fountain I'm sorry every um so what's
that is that the yeah
in a fast food place of any kind that
has an orange drink it's it's almost
exclusively that is because it's owned
by the Coca-Cola Company I'm positive
okay that's fine that's why I have to go
up the ladder because who does who owns
Capri Sun here's my point though
uh okay a German company the Germans
made it in 69. God you're it's looking
worse and worse for you it's independent
I I got a nazi-owned company can I say
something else
fun allegedly yeah there's a fun there's
a fun um tactile feeling to an unopened
Capri Sun as well there's a weight to
the bag I dare you to have it in your
hand and not like kind of toss it in the
air and catch it what are you talking
what the hell are you talking about
right now it's almost like it's almost
like uh what are you talking again you
know what you could do
you can play cornhole with a Capri Sun
you can't play cornhole with a juice box
that I see
yeah a juice box of Hi-C he's got to do
a 20-minute set later tonight he already
told us he's shot he's shot it's been
too long I really do like holding a
priest Capri Sun is a nice it's a
perfect weight to it it is it's just fun
it's fun to like kind of like it's mush
it around let me get back to my point
it's fine just smooshing around let me
get back to my point which is these two
drinks these two Juice drinks right are
the only these are the two I remember is
cracking up yeah yeah no it's funny
these are the two that I don't know why
they've made I speak the truth insane
right now every food somehow ends up in
your handshake combos name the third bib
now you're gonna pile on that nice trail
mix you say it about every you said
about M M's this is batshit you
everything
I like to do that we've had we've had
114 battles covering 228 Foods I've said
it about four Foods no no no no no 10
times maybe but I like that I do I like
I like but here listen to my let me make
this point it's parties how I consume
these two Juice drinks are the two
Titans yours are in Lunchables mine are
at the soda fountains okay with that in
mind I challenge you to name a flavor of
Capri Sun that is as popular as high sea
orange Capri Sun I gotta go original
they don't have a staple flavor that you
go holy [__] that's the move you're rich
what is the origin I don't even know
what the origin is
but you know what it is I mean you drank
it they've come a long way I mean I'm
not up to date on my pre-sun flavors I
mean
maybe a fruit punch which we started you
know or Heist maybe maybe blind taste
test babe we didn't start but blind
taste tests to 100 people
are they liking Capri Sun on the high
scene better
I missed that Capri Sun by the way
scroll it back up pimp I think Capri Sun
has a orange I haven't seen I haven't
seen just the regular flavors of Capri
Sun in a long time yeah that are just
straight up the the one fruit
they're getting two Schmitz now
everything is like Mystic Breeze and all
this [__] yeah can you tell me what the
original uh uh Capri Sun flavor is
comprised of
let's see
they had better commercials as well well
Capri Sun is now doing alcohol great
jingle
oh wow they're expanding they're really
growing expanding and pushing soil's the
brand I don't understand that no it
doesn't because all of us who drank a
preset as a kid now have a reason to
access it again at our age right now
yeah that's great and I'm sure all the
drunks will be recycling their pouches
1969 Capri Sun is born under its former
named Capri's son s-o-n-n-e exclamation
point
for the very first time a beverage in a
stand-up pouch is sold in Germany the
first flavors are lemon and orange
orange yeah I thought it was orange uh
oh lemon not lemonade lemon well no
that's 60 something what is like you
know when it came to us I thought it was
I thought it had an orange oh no it's
also filled with stevia that that
like what do you think I see us filled
with aspartame Stevia I'm sure it's the
same thing yeah just just don't I mean
look up High season look you this
artificial sweeteners in high C it's not
the [__] it's not mother's milk
organic [__] [__] look at this
dude first of all right out of the gate
high C here's the other two names I'm
seeing Minute Maid and uh which is by
the way the other big Juice Box thing
that you're saying is right is Minute
Maid is the other big one
same company
a marketing ploy to tell you that it has
vitamin C in it oh that is low down
dirty and the shame plus that is wild to
tell kids to insinuate that the C in
high C stands for vitamin C and to make
it to make them act like it might be
nutritional for them to have is is
literally a crime it's a crime Capri Sun
doesn't do that babe we had gum we had
gum we had Hershey gum
there's a rapper named after high c i c
is you know I mean I see I mean vitamin
C
no there's a rapper named after high
school sure there's one named Capri Sun
guarantee there's nothing free son
McDonald's headlines were made with
McDonald's restaurants announced oh you
[__] yeah read it we're discontinuing
I see orange lover burst
you blame me for Mystic Breeze you have
lava burst
it sounds sexual
uh from their beverage menu replacing it
with carbonated Sprite Tropic Berry
flavor soda and Fanta as part of a new
promotional deal with Coca-Cola so
Coca-Cola said we're gonna pull it out
McDonald's announced at high sea orange
lovers will officially be returning baby
[Laughter]
I see Ecto Cooler drink appears in
season four of Rick and Morty season
something of Loki the bear
uh well Ecto Cooler is pop culture for
sure
is for McDonald's kids that look at
abandoned ditches oh wow
wow
um okay can you read me the artificial
sweeteners in Hi-C please and do you
have anything to say about the marketing
of high C can I post that is that is
very criminal you know that right to
make children believe that original
parents to believe like oh no it's
getting his Vitamin C it said originally
that's where it came from in 1946. okay
you know you just blamed Capri Sunshine
Coca-Cola doesn't have cocaine in it
anymore that's still what it was named
after you know what I mean I'm sure
that's still what they're going for I
don't think so I think we're all pretty
aware go to high seas Wikipedia page you
smell delicious
spaghetti sauce right now like tomato
gravy
no like wafting in from outside no
I do where do you think that's coming
from I don't maybe a local restaurant
made by Minute Maid division of
Coca-Cola so you guys got big guns
behind you already my guy's Scrappy a
DIY guy there's no one above him Capri
Sun
Hi-C has the Death Star behind it bro
we're we're Wu-Tang over here it says
that high sea orange does contain 100 of
the recommended daily value of vitamin C
right it is also made with real fruit
artificial sweeteners and other natural
flavors all right so what's good 100 100
of vitamin C is such [__] it's I
mean it has it but they throw it in
there but they said it they wouldn't lie
to us good people but the point is that
they're doing that they
to make it look like the thing is
it's got 100 of your vitamin C in it
these little cartons May deliver all no
that's that's what I see what's what's
in uh Capri I see is only 10 juice
25 grams of sugar in a 6.75 ounce pouch
of Hi-C all right there's Capri Sun 100
juice variety pack what's let's go down
to it is there really there you go I
love it I want to see what it says
okay okay high C has more sugar per
ounce than a regular Coke okay Capri Sun
100 juice variety pack
all natural ingredients no artificial
colors flavors or preservatives
oh hold on wait wait wait I want a [__]
hold on wait I wanna I want pimp please
yeah it's just like an ad for something
I just want to see what it is it's uh
goat but pimp scroll down here right is
there a is there an ingredient you know
does one of the pictures have the Nutri
the nutrition uh list that's what I'm
looking for ingredients apple grape and
strawberry juices from concentrate never
good
it's a hundred percent juice no
artificial colors flavors or
preservatives and no high fructose corn
syrup what it says give me a [__]
hold on when it says from concentrate
what what what's in the concentrate
because sometimes they get away with a
little sneaky thing that way just give
it up Joe
high C is 10 fruit juice with artificial
flavor concentrate is a bad thing
fruit juice from country is made of from
Mostly fresh fruit fruit countries
produced by filtering water out and
fruit pulp concentrate product is stored
under
aseptic and non-aseptic and Frozen
condition I feel bad about that
what's so bad about that unless
additional sweeteners are added you may
be surprised to hear the juice from
concentrate and juice from not
concentrate have the same nutritional
value unless additional sweeteners are
added so how do I know no no no no you
you read yourself into a hole and
I'm going to the chair all right
[Laughter]
sometimes I hope you would go to the
chair
go ahead
be honest about what what do you want to
be honest you write yourself into a hole
that was all positive stuff about the
Capri Sun okay we don't know what the
concentrate is in is in the concentrate
you're gonna hang your dumb hat on that
you were talking a big game and you said
it's loaded with all this stuff and you
just read that it's actually and high C
can't make any of those claims okay
that's just that's a strike for you and
a positive for me you could admit it all
right it's gonna happen all right mind
you get 100 of your vitamin C and by the
way this hundred percent all the
diabetes this hundred percent of your
all-natural juice Capri Suns I've never
seen one of those in the goddamn wild in
my life not once and those aren't the
ones they're packing in the Lunchables
my fine feathered friend okay you don't
know that no no you don't know that I
silly Lunchables I do know that you
don't know that yes well then you have
bigger problems
you don't know what they're packing in
there you never see one in the wild they
exist we just pulled them up they sell
them at Walmart buddy
I've pulled the Tropical Breeze out of
that [__] lunchable more than
anything I can ever remember all right
I'm telling you I don't know man I think
I think I think I have some pretty good
points on my side
uh well yeah I mean I guess so we didn't
mention the jingle in the commercials
Caprice on a better marketing they did I
don't remember what the Capri sunset
[Music]
sounds memorable
high C what do you got
I gotta be honest with you dude I don't
know that I've ever seen commercial it
just it was always there it's like the
sun it just was there I know I don't
know original Capri Sun
all natural right on the banner [__] I
gotta [__] yeah
see how the kid couldn't get the thing
in they show it open one
[Music]
that was
hold on watch
right there right there that's right he
was looking at that ass by the way they
got children
in this commercial they got 10 year olds
in bikinis this is weird
don't you tried to sell it like he
couldn't get it in because of the way
that it was manufactured JG was watching
that hot piece of it free son just did a
Lenny and Squiggy
slow it down please
slow it down
go back go back come back let's see
we don't know what that is buddy that's
okay well keep playing when they show
the kids in the bikinis I promise that's
one of them
see
but I don't see any adults in this
commercial didn't have a single adult in
the commercial yeah yeah except the one
that walked by I will get you to show
their face they don't show their toys I
will give you this I see a 12 year old
kids not allowed to like a 12 year old
girl they didn't look twelve bub 11 10.
nine eight nine six seven five four
three two alone you're at the beach
alone flying kites uh I will tell you
this
is only one like 80s like wow that's 80s
and 90s like rad dude 90s baby Capri Sun
Takes the Cake yeah high C is much more
touches your heart as a child you know
running through the grass with the
sprinklers on that kind of thing what
are you what are you doing what do you
mean what am I doing what are you doing
why how could you adapt how are you
drawing a comparison of that I see is it
touches your heart it's like running
through the grass I'm saying when I
think of how I see I think more of like
of like the purity of childhood and
Capri Sun I think of more fun like oh
man I remember when I was in high school
like seeing a commercial like that and
getting excited to drink High scene
you're attaching High seeds I'm giving
Capri Sun credit and saying like a high
c commercial would not give me The Vibes
I got you're gonna from seeing the
children in their babies
I think a lot and when we go to the
phones is that you're going to see a lot
of Ecto Cooler talk and yes and that's
all you're gonna that's a majority of
what you say I feel I feel good all
right let's go take away Ecto Cooler
you knock down a couple of pedestals
before being honest with high C no take
away the Ecto Cooler no the Ecto Cooler
is an orange but the Ecto Cooler is
right there it's a left and a right fish
take away put one fist behind your back
you've taken away you can't roll your
eyes at high CR high C oranges the
Coca-Cola of juices I'm just saying like
it's the one I'm just saying you take
away that Ecto Cooler and you are not as
formidable you're just not so a lot of
stuff like lies in Ecto Cooler not high
C I would say it's like saying if you
took away Coke Zero or Cherry Coke Coke
is not as formidable I don't agree with
that high C orange is a Titan dude there
is never High see anything else on that
Fountain ever ever ever ever ever ever
and I know you make fun for did I bring
up McDonald's a lot but it is the
biggest restaurant chain in the world
and that is on every Fountain dude
because they signed a deal with
Coca-Cola it's not because of any other
reason they have Coca-Cola problems
thick you think but you think McDonald's
won't kick a [__] to the curb
[Music]
I don't know about that bro please dude
they never have dude they did they got
rid of icy orange when it was time for
sprite also he kicked a [__] to the
curb and they brought down the orange
little [__]
all right Chris Rock selective outrage
um I like this comment which one does
that Capri Sun because stabbing a little
pouch with a straw really cured a lot of
anger issues for me as a five-year-old I
get it I said it's something about it's
it's an experience it's therapeutic it's
cathartic wait wait wait scroll back up
pimp just one if high C is good enough
for McDonald's it's good enough for me
thank you all right all right I am I
couldn't see I'm throwing in those those
plastic bottles okay okay
every single poll I you you just did
I
okay
oh no it was it was okay uh I see his
report ideas for
porns always makes me laugh every time
if I wanted to drink a box of [__] I'd
stick a straw in the cat's litter box
high C is more versatile even great
Frozen oh that's interesting I never did
that
high C Ecto Cooler enough said hey
McDonald's has one of those thank you Hi
C I only know it as the orange drink
from McDonald's thank you we mean thank
you
I mean it's it's it's the Coca-Cola of
Juice drinks Capri Sun takes you back to
sitting by the pool with my sister in
the summertime Hi-C tastes like
chaos
I've seen people mix Hi-C and Cherry
Nyquil at a college party into jungle
juice that's the trash you get from high
sea
you guys would think differently if you
saw what color Capri Sun is looks gross
outside that impenetrable power that is
true I have spilled Capri Sun before and
it is not the color you think it's going
to be it comes out it's like it almost
looks like like a lot of times like a
urine color
even though it tastes like cherry
strawberry-ish
if you drink Capri Sun you're above the
age 12 I'm calling the police the reason
is way more fun gotta respect the pouch
Ecto Cooler
Stan by the way that's the first Echo
cooler I've seen no I said one before
if Joe picked Capri Sun he doesn't
really like McDonald's well he didn't
Capri Sun doesn't make my mouth feel
weird
Easy Choice
back in the day peach high C was the
[__] I don't know it Capri Sun all day
long boy
Capri Sun comes with the extremely
satisfying moment when you get to stab
your straw in the container high C is
for babies
Capri Sun is Claire is class high C is
100 trash
Y is nothing without Ecto Cooler please
I'm not kidding though I'm not getting
why Pisces the jodarosa of the juice
World I'll take it I'm not getting why
people are saying hi more like Pepsi
can't get rid of The Taste
uh no one well all right a couple more
I don't know who whose flavor that is
haishi because McDonald's High sea
orange is King thank you
Capri Sun all day I can rock high C but
I have to go with Capri Sun
when we were kids having Capri Sun in
the fridge gave you some clout for
whatever reason the high seed juice
boxes made you feel younger and less
cool interesting I want to give the win
to this guy
that just wrote V8 exclamation point
I think that's funny right yeah
uh you got that channel yeah yeah baby
follow at MJ Hill egas79 thanks Michael
now I already voted so I'm not gonna
scroll up until you guys are ready okay
all right we're ready this is it Humble
Pie segment we're going to the phones
roll out that pie chart pimp
whoa
whoa yo 18
000 votes
Capri Sun
66.6 to 33.4 the devil 666 wow 666 babe
that's that's I don't understand how
they exactly double
66-33 I doubled you Capri Sun did I
don't understand how they lost that
badly and I don't get where all you're
not even Capri Sun the props it deserves
but I also don't get why high C is
getting labeled as trash
I don't I never got a trashy vibe from I
see it's like juicy it's a very exciting
it's very accessible whereas I think
Capri Sun sold in like an eight pack of
pouches probably was marked up a little
higher and like maybe everyone like you
know if you had to choose the more
affordable drink maybe was high C that's
what I can gather it's just it's you
your yours is silvery like jewelry
it sexualizes children you are it's it's
the devil's drink undoubtedly I mean but
whatever that's what this is what
happens all right uh I mean I'm just
racking up the doubles he picks him he
picks him just says he said Hi C was a
beast that was gonna kill I thought so
all right well I still love you babe
love you too taste buds they come into
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
Fool's gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic I'm talking